Oh
[Music]
Rick you have noticed one of the most
wonderful and consistent patterns in the
whole universe the universe is very good
at making spinning disks our solar
system is a disk and all the planets go
around in basically the same plane and
they all go around in the same direction
why should that be their disks all over
the place I mean think about the rings
of Saturn the rings of Saturn are also
very very thin and they all go around in
the same direction galaxies spiral
galaxies are one big disk with
everything moving around a common center
disk seemed to be something that the
universe likes to make and in fact that
really is true and it has to do with a
number of things it has to do with the
force of gravity and something called
the conservation of angular momentum now
gravity is very good at bringing stuff
together and bringing it together so it
becomes denser and denser and begins to
fall into the center our solar system
formed out of a giant cloud of dust and
gas about four and a half billion years
ago it was actually many trillions of
miles across at first but it had to get
much smaller in order for the densities
to get high enough in the temperatures
also to get warm enough inside to give
birth to the Sun actually ignite a star
so you have this collapsing cloud of
dust okay well you can sort of
understand that gravity wants to bring
all that together but why does it start
to spin up there's something called the
conservation of angular momentum and and
that basically says that if anything has
any spin at all even just a little bit
of motion as gravity brings it together
and makes it smaller that spin is
accelerated it's sped up and probably
the example most people know best of all
you can actually feel this if you want
to do this but an ice skater if you've
seen an ice skater do a spin usually
what they do is that they have their
arms outstretched and they're spinning
around relatively slowly and then they
bring their arms in and they spin faster
and faster it's kind of amazing that any
person can keep their balance when they
do that that is an application of the
conservation of angular momentum you
have an extended body your arms are out
and you're spinning slowly in order to
conserve the energy in that spin as that
body becomes smaller the spin goes
faster and faster
and so what happens in these clouds is
that a cloud usually has just a tiny
little bit of a drift velocity it's
going around the galaxies or maybe a
nearby star exploded and it's kind of
all moving in one direction the cloud
itself has a little bit of velocity as a
cloud as a whole particles inside that
cloud could be going any which way but
as the cloud begins to come together
under gravity any little bit of spin
gets accelerated actually becomes faster
and so as the cloud collapses any little
directional drift becomes a spin and the
cloud itself begins to spin around okay
so that gets you a spinning cloud and
why does it collapse down into a disk
and this is an interesting bit of
physics that has to do with things like
collisions in the case of a very large
cloud that's forming a star it might not
even be that things are colliding
directly but gravitationally they're
influencing them as they as you go by as
you go by different parts of mass they
tug on each other with their gravity so
this whole cloud is spinning and things
begin to interact gravitationally they
begin to collide with each other the
particles have motion in every direction
some are going up and some are going
down and as they start to hit each other
that's kind of balanced out this bed
that up and down is sort of canceled out
but everything has the same motion as
the cloud is spinning so that's
basically the only thing that's left
over at the end everything gets canceled
out is all these things collide and
interact but the spin of the cloud is
still there and so over time you
collapse down into a disk so the only
reason you make disks is because of this
law of conservation of angular momentum
and the idea that gravity brings things
together have those two things working
side by side and you get a disk and
that's why our solar system formed that
way the planets then formed out of that
spinning disk of gas so it makes sense
that they're all going in the same
direction they all formed out of the gas
going around the Sun in that way
[Music]